hello youtube this is awesome Steiner I
had the Environment Programme United
Nations that has its home in Nairobi
Kenya I wanted to respond to this
question because much of what you may be
hearing and reading in the headlines of
newspapers and TV reports about Davos
this year is about economic slowdown
recession the Warriors of the financial
markets subprime rates and some have
been wondering what happened to the
discussion about the state of the planet
and issues such as climate change global
warming our response to it I think for
2008 our great opportunity is to show
that as we respond to the challenge of
global warming area we can do so also in
the context or perhaps some of the
economic indicators now pointing towards
a slowdown responding to climate change
is about doing things more efficiently
but investing in new markets it's about
creating your job is about bringing new
technologies in it and I think we need
to speak to our leaders the political
leaders the economic leaders this year
to make sure that we don't fall back
into the old trap of arguing that doing
something about climate change is a
luxury and if the times economically
become harder we can't afford to do it I
think the opposite is true and it will
depend on a lot of you speaking to your
Senators Congressmen and huge local
leaders and mayors because they can do a
lot easier and in particular the view to
reaching a new agreement climate change
which is what we now have to worry about
for the future bye-bye